New York's first apparent shark attacks
in more than six decades injured two
children off Long Island the two
separate incidents happened yesterday at
beaches less than five miles apart along
a popular vacation spot known as Fire
Island both beaches were temporarily
closed Don Dahler is on Fire Island near
where one of the kids was hurt Don good
morning good morning state investigators
are still trying to determine if they
were in fact shark attacks that happened
right off this shore of this popular
beach one of the victims a 12 year old
girl is scheduled to have surgery later
today to close up her wounds but she
says she has no doubt it was a shark I
looked over and I saw like this tannish
orange like fin and like body
Lola polina was enjoying a family day at
the beach when the 12 year old felt
something grabbed her leg she started
screaming for help I see her like in the
water like struggling and there was this
commotion in the water next to her it
mostly just hurt but I felt something in
there and then it like let go and I
started and I was like oh my gosh what
just happened we looked down we saw like
the the bite marks and like the blood
her parents brought her to nearby
lifeguards who evaluated her wounds and
bandaged her leg she was taken to the
hospital for further treatment I knew it
had to be something like like a shark
because there's nothing else he could
have possibly been not with those kind
of ones earlier in the morning and only
about five miles down the shore
something attacked a 13 year old boy
lifeguard Bella Cohen pulled him from
the water I noticed that he had a lot of
blood on his leg and he said that he
felt like something had bit him
emergency responders pulled this tooth
from what are the boy's wounds near his
knee state officials will examine the
tooth to determine if it came from a
shark like this one which was caught
near the site of the first attack I'm
just happy that nothing worse happened
I'm okay and like I'm not gonna you know
die shark attacks are very rare in fact
one organization that tracks them says
they were 88 worldwide last year
resulting in five deaths as for Lola she
says this isn't gonna stop her from
getting back in the water
but next time she might be a little
more careful John Don Dahler fourth and
four is there Don I want to just turn
around and run into that surf right
behind you - they are